Move over rabbits!
A new Australian marsupial is the animal to
beat when it comes to marathon sex.
Hello Everyone, welcome to DNews.
Im Crystal Dilworth, here to talk about sex
in the outback.
Animal sex in most cases, isn’t really any
weirder or more straightforward than human
sex.
In fact, behaviorist Dr. Jason Goldman has
been quoted as saying: “for just about any
fantasy between consenting adults that might
be thought of as beyond conventional sexual
practices or decency as dictated by society,
you can bet that there’s a non-human species
for whom that particular behaviour is commonplace”
and that may be true, but a special marsupial
inhabitant of Australia may be showing us
up in dedication to the cause:
Genetic analysis of several Australian marsupial
mammals called Antechinus has facilitated
classification of a another new species - this
one named The Tasman Peninsula Dusky Antechinus.
These animals are small mousy carnivores that
live in Australia, Tasmania, and New Guinea
but their claim to fame?
Suicidal sex.
Yes, thats right, Antechinus males have sex
until they literally can’t do it anymore.
Male Antechinus literally train for the task
of mating.Banking sperm and suppressing their
immune systems to give themselves more energy
for the marathon act of passing on their genetic
material.
During a mating season that lasts only a few
weeks, testosterone fueled males engage in
what has been described as an “extreme form
of ‘speed-mating.’”
In that time males attempt to have sex with
as many females as possible, lasting for anywhere
from 12 -14 hours before their bodies literally
self-destruct.
Scientists at Queensland University of Technology
say that these animals are biochemically driven
to give it their all before, ultimately, the
high level of testosterone triggers a malfunction
in the inhibition of stress hormones.
Once stress hormones begin to flood the body,
the immune system of these overtaxed males
begin to collapse and the animal usually dies
of hemorrhage or infection before they can
see the fruits of their labor.
What drives males to these extremes?
Scarcity of food and sexual competition.
Antechinus aren't the only animals who mate
until they die, suicidal reproduction is called
“semelparity” and salmon, as well as some
frogs, lizards, and many insects reproduce
this way.
But while not rare in nature, it is unusual
to see semelparity in mammals, and all of
the species that exhibit this behavior are
insect eating marsupials.
The narrow window of the mating season is
thought to follow the boom-bust nature of
the insect life cycle, synchronizing Antechinus
reproduction so that females raise their young
at times when food is most abundant.
The intensity of the resulting sexual competition
also works out for females who benefit by
mating promiscuously and just letting the
best sperm win.
This anomaly of evolution may sound like “all
play and no work” but the inefficiency of
the mating practice combined with a severely
reduced natural habitat is cutting each generation
of antechinus population in half and scientists
have already requested this newly discovered
marsupial be placed on the threatened species
list.
Leading one to speculate that this may be
an evolutionary “dead end”
Is there any other weird animal behavior you
wanna know more about?
Let us know in the comments down below.
Also check out this video with Matt and Trace
to see which other animals made the list of
weirdest new species discovered last year